No. Mitch is fine.
Still mad at me though.
You know how touchy he can be, Didi.
Remember when we tried to cheer him up after
his first ice skating competition?
Yeah. How were we supposed to know?
Third place is a good thing.
Memory tromped off across that muddy field
in his skates. He sunk like a woolly
mammoth. Hey, Didi, if you're around the 4th
of July, you should come by and watch the
wedding video. Oh, no.
We're out of town in August.
All right. Well, soon.
Okay. Oh, Didi, I don't think I have your
new.
Okay. It's magic time, everyone.
Phil, please take your place beneath our
majestic arch.
Cue the quartet. Where's the other one?
He rode with the caterer who flipped his
truck.
Why do good things happen to everyone but me?
Let's send the flower girl before she's a
flower teenager.
Oh. So sad.
Sorry.
What is. Yeah.
Like I'm the problem.
Is your dad here?
Yeah. You should be right. Oh, my God, he's
out on the sidewalk on the phone.
Do you want me to go get him?
No, no I don't. Come on, let's just do this.
Oh.
Mitchell, is this really how you want to get
married?
Well, it's not ideal now.
People don't have any rice to throw because
they're chewing it raw out of starvation.
Half of our guests are on the lawn, and
there go the sprinklers.
Okay, let's just call time of death on this.
All right.
Hey, everybody.
Um, thank you so much for, uh, for dealing
with all this today. It means a lot to us,
but unfortunately, this is not gonna.
You can't do this. Yeah.
I'm way ahead of you, Dad. And thank you for
stopping by.
What I mean is, you can't get married like
this. You two deserve the kind of wedding
you've been talking about nonstop for the
last nine months.
What do you mean?
You bring it up every chance that you get.
I know what nonstop means.
Trust me. Okay.
Now what are we all standing around for?
My son's getting married today.
All right. Jake. It's what this golf club
needs. Shake it up a little.
Go on dear. How often do your fathers get
married?
So far.
One, two.
Why am I still seeing you?
You take your seat Dad we're about to start.
Actually, I thought you and I would take a
little walk.
I remember it like it was yesterday, the day
that Mitchell came home from the hospital in
a very unfashionable white diaper with three
strands of scraggly, Raggedy Andy hair.
If he's doing it, I'm doing it.
You comin and Barb.
You all sweet talker.
Wait for me.
We were inseparable.
I was his big sister, his big brother, his
nemesis, his protector, his best friend.
I was his first partner, and I loved every
minute of it.
Thank you all for being here on this happy
occasion. They say the best marriages
contain just a little bit of magic.
Believe me, I know.
We're gathered here today to join two
amazing people.
So naturally, I was a little picky when it
came to who was going to be replacing me.
And then I met this Cam.
And sure, he was warm and funny and loving.
Cameron, do you take Mitchell to be your
husband? I do.
Cameron, would you please place this ring on
Mitchell's finger? Mitchell, do you take
Cameron to be your husband?
I do.
Then, by the powers vested in me by the state
of California, I am privileged to pronounce
you spouses for life.
You may now kiss your husband.
I wondered.
Was he really everything I wanted for my
brother?
Was he really the best person?
No. I'm the best person.
And now I am very pleased to raise a glass
and introduce, for the first time ever on
our fourth try, great husbands, Mitch and
Cam.